so here is western australian premier  mark mcgowan he has uh recorded a video  where he's trying to communicate some  basic things about about covid to the  aboriginal community in the area but  he's even hired an aboriginal elder to  translate for him in real time and the  results are  truly extraordinary you can die from the  corona or get really sick  you will again  pass away  from this groaner  or you better get really sick one  it's time to get the corona needle to  keep people and country strong  the end  he time to get him this needle longer  corona  to keep them but all the people  and country probably a strong one i  guess the big news here is i learned  just now that i speak aboriginal  australian so i i am bilingual that's uh  that's good news